Laughter.
It’s the best medicine.
It’s the glue between friends.
It’s the universal language!
But nothing sounds more contrived and obvious
than the forced laughter of strangers.
Hey!
I’m Natalia, Nice to meet you.
I really like your hair.
[forced laughter]
Hey!
It’s Natalia Reagan for DNews!
Laughter between strangers seems to lack a
genuine enthusiasm, and now science says that
“contrived nature” can be easily detected-
even across cultures!
New research shows that listeners spanning
24 societies could detect when people are
laughing with strangers versus laughing among
friends based on their spontaneity, duration,
and acoustics of their guffaws.
In this study, released in PNAS, researchers
recorded laughing pairs and had ‘listeners’
try to determine the affiliation of the laughers-were
they friends or strangers?
According to the study, “laughter is characterized
by neuromechanical oscillations involving
rhythmic laryngeal and superlaryngeal activity”.
Say that 10 times fast!
The study included 966 listeners from 24 countries
across five continents, including India, Namibia,
Peru and Slovakia listening to English speaking
laughers.
Listeners were accurate in their determinations
roughly 61% of the time.
The ‘listeners’ were not all familiar
with the English language (again, the laughers
all spoke English) but they still were able
to identify the ‘stranger’ laughers from
the friends.
The idea that laughing is a cross-cultural
universal affiliative behavior has been proven
time and again, but this supports the idea
that humans- regardless of language barrier,
can distinguish authentic from inauthentic
laughter.
But why is this important?
Let’s start at the beginning, shall we...
The history of laughter goes way, way, WAY
back, scientists surmised that human laughter
began with a common ancestor some 20 million
years ago.
That means laughter is older than language
and is a shared behavior by all humans.
Heck, as babies we learn to laugh before we
learn to speak!
And laughter is an affiliative behavior, meaning
one that helps form cohesion between individuals
of a group.
Other affiliative behaviors, include touching,
hugging, playing, and grooming!
Laughter helps forge bonds between individuals.
And laughing feels good.
Why?
That’s because it suppresses the release
of stress hormones like cortisol while releasing
the feel good hormone, dopamine.
Evolutionarily speaking, forming affiliative
bonds and coalitions was AND is vital for
survival.
Being able to read groups of people from audio
cues is important.
And even though laughter is often the result
of a humorous moment, comedy isn’t the only
cause for laughter.
According to the Encyclopedia of Linguistics,
laughter is an integral part of human conversation.
Linguistic analysis of conversations have
found that laughter often occurs at the end
of a talking turn between individuals as an
invitation to share in joint laughter.
And since humans are heavily dependent on
our ability to communicate with one another,
laughing is an effective way to give immediate
feedback during a conversation, regardless
if it’s rife with hilarity.
Given the significant role that laughter plays
in our species existence, it’s no wonder
humans across cultures have developed the
ability to determine affiliations based on
laughter, regardless if they speak the same
language.
What about you?
Have you ever used laughter to communicate
with someone who doesn’t speak your language?
Test it out and tell us how you did in the
comments below!
And to find out more about why we laugh, here’s
Trace’s with the scoop!